okay well let's see what we are
discussing here is some details about
synthetic geometry this may be fairly
short the issue is whether how to handle
the evaluation of geometric assertions
so what is this so this is the triangle
with sides a B and C why is that
there are many such triangles right am I
very crystal orientation I mean we don't
have something like ma T - right I mean
that the food triangle guys all give
something I believe with a corner at the
origin right and or yet I don't do x
axis I mean otherwise they wouldn't be
graphically displayed if you take over
lense clauses motivations and
translations no I understand that
I understand that it's good that they
are I'm just I'm wondering why the I
mean if I so if I would say um I didn't
even know this worked this is cool
actually
okay so I don't understand why that's
like that you it's even a it's done
trivially right and it's going it's
going counterclockwise right from the
origin counterclockwise from the origin
that's very hard to understand so look
at the ref page there's still a bunch of
normalizations it needs to do like it
has to put it somewhere it has to pick
an orientation yeah yeah with a at the
origin hey which is adjacent which is
the opposite angle to that okay I get it
little odd but yeah I get it okay okay
geometric solve and geometric solve
value what is this here I mean let's go
back to what's the issue attend issue
attend was email from you about you go
there you asserted that there was one
nine and there was a polyline and they
were part of it and you expected to get
to did it would evil eight also the
intrastate the sink but this in
geometric scene the only one statement
we don't want evaluation we just want to
state things even trivial things because
we might want to plot them in white or
just item they do it shouldn't send
evaporate away okay so your claim is
that if I do this that the correct
behavior is absolutely nothing exactly I
wish you don't want to blob this in any
way but that output I mean just as a
display thing I have no opinion of this
I mean maybe but I don't I'm not sure we
gain very much right I mean the point is
that this is a you know sort of an
assertion of things and you know if we
hide what you're asserting it becomes
much less yeah okay well it's just
it looks like a bad square or is percent
value I think yeah oh I died you
something goofy yeah okay so right if
you wanted to just get fall seenu's
geometric solve value i'll give it so
explain to me okay so here so here if I
change that to - I'll get true okay I
shouldn't be geometric resolve we had
this discussion but because we wanted
geometric solve any way to solve for
sings we thought this is kind of saw for
something but we had this discussion if
we solve is not a little bit better
suited my main I mean my main argument
against resolve and it's you know not a
super strong opposition but resolve is
you know our resolve resolves
quantifiers and we don't have any
quantifiers quantified statements in
general here right why is this got
double lists buckets
um because multiple solutions in
principle just like solves right so
having the left hand side here be that
whole geometric assertion seems quite
odd right also normally solved in this
case we'd and just return an empty list
or empty double lists so I just added
that in there not a strong opinion on
that
so if you do like solve of true
I am completely confused by this result
Y XY Y are the x and y values in a
separate sub list from the Z value
that's a separate solution right right
so this was just hitting it with solve
at the end so yeah there's a separate
solution if X is not 0 or X is 0
wait a minute if x and y 0 then I
understand Z what did they don't
collinear 1 and Z and then you have two
points to 0 0 and 1 comma Z right really
collinear oh I see yes ok ok um
it seems like probably the thing you're
more of you looking for would be a
geometric solve value which of the last
part of this last we show that just
gives true or false err
well what's that doing that's pretty
weird that's a condition right so if if
you for instance had concrete values of
x y and z where this was done it would
give true or false right but I don't
understand this I mean that's a very
different thing Roger from our other
value like things which give values
we're getting certain oh you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right you're right you're right
so okay I guess the more interesting
question is could what this inferred
could we give you know solve variables
in principle here in which case you
could get for Z in terms of Y and X when
this assertion is true right so this is
a one argument form could we have a two
argument form where you specify what to
solve for I think yes because we want to
use geometric solve in the generic case
for things like solve the lengths of
triangle H or so so for ages yeah and
you don't wanna be generating everything
we want the two argument form to be a
geometric scene and the thing to solve
for but so maybe like solve for these
particular variables would be a third
argument that's nice that's very nice
okay well I don't
I have an objection to this Roger do you
have a comments on this but this seems
very nice to me okay
the only question I have as are you okay
I would have had comments if we boasted
about Chris Tennant impacts on a lot of
things right are you okay with this this
geometric assertion for the geometric
solve of something that's that's already
true or false of having you know Jim at
the whole expression go to true or false
because that is thank you let's think
about that for a moment okay all right
that is unlike our other solve functions
let me try to understand this so
normally it would have some parameter
values for example it would say oh gosh
I'm help me walk me through why this
makes sense I think it's a slightly PD
question like right now we have a
certain idea of what our variables in
salt like they're basically these are
single symbols or symbol of something or
nested versions or subscript or
something like this maybe in Syria me
see this alphabet site people are
sketchy like they give a set of equation
and then say so 4x plus 3y we can't do
this because we cannot solve for things
that has plus x power so but in general
people want to solve for certain
compound objects so I think it's in this
spirit of what we begged you do and what
I should be able to support that but by
the way can we do it in alpha so for it
so I I mean I have a comment which is a
bit tangential but also sort of but also
very much getting at this point which is
the the foo value functions that we have
take the thing to solve for but also the
expression whose value you want to
return right so this one argument for
of geometric solve value is a weird I
mean I suppose we could have you know if
you give to one argument form it's you
know give the value of the first
argument but the whole one of the big
powerful things about the value
functions is that you know you write if
I do dissolve value I can ask for it to
give me Y and Y Prime in a list and that
way I can easily create phase portraits
yeah right but I think it's okay that
the default for the second argument is
just the first argument which is what's
going on here all right I mean in fact
and that again makes it consistent this
thing with the actual first argument on
the left-hand side makes it consistent I
guess I mean one could imagine I think
that's okay I mean basically the the
whole reason we we decided to go with
these new geometric solve value and
geometric solve functions is most of the
existing functions require that second
argument we did not want to which exist
you mean as opposed to going for a sole
value or something we'd use yeah reduce
like reduce actually lines up somewhat
well with what we're doing except it
doesn't have a one argument form and
similar like it I pointed out to resolve
would be a one argument version but it
typically for sauce only quantifiers and
we don't have any 1/10 all right this
seems fine
Roger any lost comments no no I think
this looks fine to okay
Fick right okay good thanks thanks mate
okay bye-bye